autre grandeur et misère nous sommes
allés à leur rencontre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pensais que tout le monde connaissait
déjà kim philby le plus fameux des
espions britanniques après james bond
rappelez-nous pourquoi il s'est tourné
vers le communisme il pensait que la
gauche s'étaient vendus il se disait la
démocratie la démocratie sociale ne fait
pas le travail et il a vu l'avènement
d'hitler en allemagne donc il regardait
l'union soviétique comme un bastion anti
fasciste
l'un des éléments clés selon as
concernant philby
c'est que tout le monde a sous-estimé la
force de son engagement idéologique
l'autre chose qu'il ne faut pas oublier
à son sujet et qu'il avait des capacités
extraordinaires pour la tromperie
c'était un menteur tout à fait brillant
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mardi 15 février sommes
nous à l'heure de l'apaisement dans la
crise ukrainienne le chancelier allemand
olaf scholz affirme ce soir qu'il ya
suffisamment de base de discussion avec
la russie après sa rencontre aujourd'hui
avec vladimir poutine à moscou le
président russe qui demandent toujours
lui des garanties sur l'extension de
l'otan de leur côté emmanuel macron et
joe biden disent vouloir vérifier le
début d'un retrait russe plus tôt dans
la journée moscou avait effectué un
retrait partiel processus normal
habituelles selon le kremlin dans le
cadre de ces exercices militaires à la
frontière
près de 4 millions français pourrait
perdre leur pass vaccinale avec le
passage de six à quatre mois du délai
pour réaliser sa dose de rappel c'est ce
qu'indique le ministère de la santé qui
a tout même annoncé à un délai de
tolérance d'une semaine durcissement
donc du pass vaccinale d'un côté mais
levée progressive des restrictions de
l'autre les discothèques fermaient
depuis deux mois peuvent rouvrir ou
encore les concerts de l'ue peuvent
reprendre le protocole en vigueur à
l'école sera lui adapté à partir du 21
février
au sommaire à 21h cette question
l'échangé téléphonique entre eric
zemmour et donald trump qui pousse ou
coup d'épée dans l'eau pendant 40
minutes le candidat à la présidentielle
française s'est entretenu avec l'ancien
chef de l'état américain selon le parti
la reconquête trump a conseillé aux
polémistes de tenir bon notamment face
aux médias alors le milliardaire peut-il
vraiment considérer exe moore comme un
nouvel allié eric zemmour trump même
combat le débat sera ouvert
un dialogue france était la tonalité de
la rencontre aujourd'hui entre la rolls
et vladimir poutine le chancelier
allemand et le président russe sont
entretenus plusieurs heures à moscou
pour tenter de trouver une issue à la
crise ukrainienne on retrouve notre
correspondante veraguas hoffman dans la
capitale russe bonsoir verra que faut-il
donc retenir de ces échanges russo
allemand aujourd'hui
bonsoir stéphanie trois heures de
négociations la rencontre entre all of
choice et de la dîmière poutine a pris
fin aucun blindé tout en éventail de
sujets a été évoquée mais une attention
particulière a été accordée évidemment
la crise ukrainienne vladimir poutine a
déclaré que la russie ne veut pas de
guerre mais la situation actuelle où la
l'infrastructure de le temps est aux
frontières russes suscite l'inquiétude
de la russie surtout compte tenu du fait
que le temps a par le passé déjà attaqué
un pays européens il s'agissait des
bombardements de la serbie en 1999 ce
qui va ensuite se baser sur le continent
européen pour vladimir poutine ne dépend
pas uniquement de la russie je vous
propose d'écouter
comment la russie va agir en suède qui
peut répondre à la question de savoir
comment dans les circonstances actuelles
les choses dans son coin on ne sait pas
personne ne le sait ça ne dépend pas que
de moi mais nous avons la tension et
nous allons chercher à faire en sorte
que nous puissions nous entendre avec
nos partenaires sur les questions qui
ont été posées par non
pour qu'elle soit résolue
diplomatiquement nous sommes tout à fait
prêts à des discussions
nous sommes prêts aussi à
discuter
à dialoguer mais toutes les questions
qui ont été comme sujet les doubles jeux
les 10 précédemment ce doivent pas être
étudiée dans l'optique que des
préoccupations que la russie a défini
comme priorités quant à olaf scholz et
l'a reconnu qu'ils existent en nombre de
désaccords entre la russie et
l'allemagne ainsi que des désaccords au
niveau russie otan mais pour le
chancelier allemand l'important est que
les dialogues continus écoutez je suis
d'accord avec le fait du les
impossibilités diplomatiques ne sont pas
être épuisées pour le moment maintenant
elle est important de vrai avec
persévérance à résoudre cette crise nous
avons entendu des déclarations de que
certain détachement or
reprennent leur nom pour leurs zones de
déploiement permanent nous nous en
réjouissons il est important aussi de
poursuivre les négociations avec nos
alliés de l'otan pour les allemands et
les pv dans que la sécurité un fiable ne
peut pas être construite alors détriment
de l'est russie ça doit être fait
ensemble avec les la russie il faut
trouver un simple la solution si
compliqué que soit cette tâche je ne
trouve pas que on est déjà dans
l'impasse il faut vrai avec audace et
avec responsabilité
faut rappeler que la rencontre du
chancelier allemand avec le président
russe s'est tenue sur fond de
spéculations concernant l'imminence
d'une attaque us en ukraine selon
bloomberg cette agence de presse
américaine la russie aurait dû commencer
son offensive aujourd'hui même vers amos
quoi pourtant annoncé ce matin la fin
des exercices militaires dans l'ouest et
le retour d'unités militaires dans leurs
garnisons
oui pour le porte parole du kremlin
dmitri peskov le retour de ses forces
dans leurs garnisons est une étape
logique
au terme des manoeuvres d'entraînement
il a déclaré que la russie a mené
continuera de mener des exercices
militaires sur l'ensemble de son
territoire en soulignant que c'était un
droit inaliénable du pays de mener des
exercices là où ils le considèrent
approprié la fin des exercices
militaires a été également commenté par
le chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov pour lui l'organisation de tes
entraînements ne dépend pas je cite de
l'hystérie et du de ce qui fonde une
terrorisme informationnel dans sa
conversation avec le chef de la
diplomatie américaine anthony blinken
sergueï lavrov a notamment fait savoir
que la rhétorique agressive exacerbée
par washington et ses alliés étaient
inadmissibles écoutez
voici donc la position actuelle de
l'occident nous exigeons que la russie
arrête ces exercices qu'elle retire ses
troupes
la russie avait planifié cela et exécute
ses plans le moment est désormais venu
de terminer partiellement ces exercices
elles commencent à retourner sur leurs
lieux de déploiement permanent
et l'occident déclare immédiatement je
vous l'assuré si l'occident ne l'a pas
encore dit qu'il va forcément dire vous
voyez nous avons fait pression sur eux
hayden a crié un coup immédiatement pris
peur et ont satisfait nos exigences
voilà tout on vend du vent nos collègues
occidentaux sont très très fort là
dessus nous devons apprendre à faire de
tels entourloupe
le 15 février le porte parole du
ministère russe de la défense igor
konachenkov a affirmé que les troupes
russes stationnées à proximité de la
frontière avec l'ukraine avaient entamé
leur retour vers leurs lieux de
stationnement mais enfin exercices
militaires menées par la russie
merci verhaeghe hoffman en direct de
moscou est alors que les tensions à
redessan donc d'un cran dans cette crise
ukrainienne les députés russes de la
douma ont voté un appel au président
vladimir poutine pour qu'il reconnaisse
l'indépendance des républiques
autoproclamées du dombass et ados nièce
éloquence qu'une proposition condamné
par la diplomatie européenne de son côté
venir poutine a réagi sur le sujet ont
fait le point avec notre envoyé spécial
antoine claireaux à donetsk les
autorités de la république autoproclamée
de donetsk se félicite de la proposition
des députés russes qui invite vladimir
poutine à reconnaître les deux
républiques populaires du donbass en
tant qu'etat indépendant et souverain et
pour le dirigeant de la rpdc le fait que
l'ukraine accroisse sa présence
militaire le long de la ligne de contact
signifie que kiev n'a pas l'intention de
respecter les accords de kiev nie de
résoudre le conflit de façon pacifique
il estime donc que la voie vers une
reconnaissance peut désormais être
ouverte le discours à la douma d'état
avant le vote était très révélateur ils
ont montré à quel point les
parlementaires prennent à coeur les
problèmes des habitants du donbass à
quel point ils compatissent à tout ce
qui se passe dans les républiques à quel
point ils sont préoccupés par la menace
existante émanant de l'ukraine et de
l'occident nous remercions les députés
de la douma d'état pour les résultats du
vote d'aujourd'hui dans le même temps
nous traiterons tous décision des hauts
dirigeants de la fédération de russie
avec compréhension et respect dans ses
derniers mots sont toutefois la prudence
des propos du dirigeant de la rpdc bien
lui en a pris car en effet venir poutine
a réagi sur ce sujet c'était lors de sa
conférence de presse commune avec le
chancelier allemand nous partirons du
principe que
il faut faire pour que le problème du
donbass soit résolu mais il faut le
faire comme l'a dit monsieur le
chancelier fédéral avant tout
sur la base des vases des possibilités
et des accords de minsk qui n'ont pas
encore été mises en oeuvre en espérant
que nos partenaires
outre atlantique et en europe c'est à
dire la france et l'allemagne pourront
exercer une influence suffisante sur les
autorités de kiev pour qu' une solution
ce sens soit adopté les autorités
locales ici dans le donbass sont à
l'affût de toute solution politique qui
pourrait améliorer le sort de la
population mais pour l'exécutif russe la
voie diplomatique c'est à dire
l'application stricte des accords de
minsk reste la seule alternative viable
pour mettre un terme au conflit dans le
donbass d'autant que la reconnaissance
par moscou des deux territoires celui de
donetsk est celui de lougansk serait
particulièrement mal vus sur la scène
internationale pour paris cela
s'apparenterait par exemple à une
agression sans armes alors faut-il voir
un vrai apaisement dans la crise
ukrainienne comme le laisse entendre
notamment la fiole ce après sa visite
aujourd'hui à moscou quelle lecture de
cette rencontre entre le chancelier
allemand et vladimir poutine pourquoi la
presse anglo saxonne continue-t-elle de
spéculer sur l'invasion ukrainienne par
la russie détaillé l'est puis alors
qu'un retrait partiel a été annoncée à
la frontière c'est l'heure de notre
décryptage
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler xavier
moreau fondateur de strates paul en
direct avec nous bonsoir xavier moreau
sur ce plateau régis le sommier grand
reporter arte france ainsi que le
général dominique traquant expert en
géostratégie bonsoir à tous les deux
également beaucoup parlent ce soir
d'apaisement olaf scholz le premier qui
affirme qu'il ya suffisamment de base de
discussion avec la russie pour déboucher
sur des solutions positives
registre soumis on se demande
concrètement qu'est ce qui a changé
aujourd'hui
puisque finalement vladimir poutine ne
cesse de répéter la même chose depuis le
début ce qui a changé c'est la faim fait
c'est le calendrier qui était militaire
qui a été établi comme ça la fin des
commandes et exercices des manoeuvres
entre l'armée russe c'est l'armé de
biens russes qui se sont déroulés
effectivement dans une zone proche de la
frontière pour une part et qu'une partie
de ses troupes à a regagné ses casernes
en début de matinée et là on a senti que
effectivement il y avait une forme
d'apaisement ou en tout cas il y avait
quelque chose d'un point de vue
militaire qui pouvait changer la donne
c'était le c6 normale et le calendrier
qu'il fallait au stade où on en met deux
de l'exacerbation de cette crise chaque
mouvement de soldats et regarder et
scruté à la loupe les deux protagonistes
dans cette histoire voyant ce que les
uns et les autres font et évidemment
interprétant et voilà et ensuite si vous
avez toute la planète médiatique pour un
pour interpréter ça donc ça c'est des
signes ensuite après vous avez cette
visite en effet du chancelier allemand
qui est n'est pas finalement
fondamentalement différente de du
message qui en est qui étaient ressortis
de de la visite des manuels macron quand
on voit il ya l'idée toujours d'essayer
de te rechercher des solutions que la
crise est complexe que voilà on ne va
pas avoir un accord comme ça dans
l'immédiat d'un point de vue russe il ya
eu aussi l'idée faut regarder les choses
de ne pas appuyer sur le détonateur
c'est à dire de ne pas reconnaître
immédiatement en tout cas procéder à ce
qui était demandé à la douma de
reconnaître les républiques autonomes de
l'est donc ça c'est déjà une chose donc
on est quand même dans une situation où
aujourd'hui
en deux en dehors je dirais de la presse
anglo saxonne on et qui continuent elles
comme l'invité de d'aller sur un espèce
de pouce à la guerre comme on a déjà vu
par le passé 1 c'est exactement la même
le même scénario que pendant la guerre
en irak ou d'autres guerres ou tout à
coup les journalistes américains sont à
coup c'est je dirais open bar c'est à
dire qu'on peut raconter relayée j'ai vu
des confrères très honorable au
demeurant dans leur travail
journalistique relayer comme ça sans
filtre des vidéos de propagande de
l'armée ukrainienne seulement d'un point
de vue journalistique ça me choque je
souhaiterais que ce soit mise en
contexte et qu'on ne fasse pas de dire
voilà tout à coup comme si c'était un
jeu de société c'est la guerre quand
même voilà on va en parler effectivement
du rôle de ces médias général traquant
une partie des cent mille hommes
déployés autour de l'ukraine donc sont
retournés dans la garnison la russie qui
a d'ailleurs montré diffusé des images
de blindés ce soit à manuel macro et joe
biden disent vouloir vérifier l'annoncé
d'un début du retrait russe autour des
frontières de l'ukraine vous le général
le militaire comment ça se passe ça ne
suffit pas de montrer ces images il faut
vérifier pourquoi cette demande
américaine et française il faut vérifier
le retrait du dispositif effectivement
ce n'est pas parce qu'on embarque
quelques chars sur des trains que le
dispositif en lui-même pas on parle si
vous voulez du on passe du discours au
fait pour reprendre ce qui vient d'être
dit c'est à dire qu'avant c'était nous
n'attaquerons pas nous n'attaquerons pas
nous n'attaquerons pas maintenant c'est
l'effet effectivement le départ on
arrive enfin et les anglo saxons les
américains et britanniques en
particulier ont pas encore complètement
réalisée à la fin de la période de
tension des deux côtés c'est à dire que
la mobilisation qui avait du côté russe
a mené la tension et de l'autre côté le
discours américain a mené la tension le
but du président
poutine pardon était essentiellement
qu'on prenne en compte les nouvelles
structures de sécurité qu'ils souhaitent
voir met en place il veut vraiment bien
sûr n'a pas changé ça n'a pas changé
mais donc j'ai mis la pression pour
qu'enfin on regarde ce problème de
sécurité de l'autre côté l'appel de
tension qui monte vous citiez layrac
j'étais à new york en 2003 comme je me
souviens très bien cette espèce
d'emballement pour faire monter les
choses qui a deux effets le premier
c'est que tous les européens se sont
regroupés sous les ailes de l'otan
maintenant quand dans une semaine on va
voir que la russie n'a pas attaqué est
ce que les européens vont réaliser enfin
qu'on leur a raconté des balivernes que
les américains ont raconté des choses
qui n'étaient pas vraies et que donc il
faut se méfier de ça et le deuxième
point dont on parle pas beaucoup mais
quand même important c'est le sujet
économique l'économie ukrainienne on a
pris un sacré coup
les bourses se sont effondrées un peu
partout il ya des gens qui doit se faire
beaucoup d'argent sur cette crise et ça
il faut pas l'oublier et puis la sphère
du pétrole bien sûr le pétrole est à 100
$ au jeu mais voilà donc il faut prendre
en compte tous ces éléments là alors
dans la lumière de cette prudence à
l'otan est évidemment allé sur forcément
les etats-unis et la france a tenu un
discours de prudence également et and
stripes under qui a tenu aujourd'hui une
conférence de presse on l'écouté
jusqu'à présent nous n'avons pas vu de
désescalade sur le terrain ni de signes
d'une diminution de la présence
militaire russe aux frontières de
l'ukraine
mais nous continuerons à surveiller et à
suivre de près ce que fait la russie et
les signaux indiquant que moscou y prête
à poursuivre les efforts diplomatiques
nous pouvons être prudemment optimistes
mais nous allons bien sûr suivre de très
près ce qui se passe sur le terrain et
c'est cela se traduit par une véritable
escalade du renforcement militaire russe
en ukraine et dans les environs
cette déclaration du secrétaire général
de l'otan et ce soir les états unis qui
demandent à la russie une désescalade
invérifiables et significatif anthony
blinken qui la demandaient à sergueï
lavrov xavier moreau on sent quand même
que la confiance n'est pas totalement
établi pour l'heure même si on aimait
dessiner optimiste
écoutez tout se déroule à peu près comme
nous l'avions dit sur votre votre chaîne
entre autres c'est à dire que le
psychodrame de la fausse tentative
d'invasion ruche est en train de
s'étouffer puisque ni les états unis ni
la russie n'ont intérêt à un conflit en
ukraine la russie elle n'a qu'à attendre
que l'effondrement qui en plus s'est
accélérée à cause de ce psychodrame de
l'économie ukrainienne et blinken
prépare les pardons et joe biden prépare
les mid term au point de vente qui
s'annonce catastrophique donc finalement
les choses sont redevienne comme elle
devait être donc là évidemment on est
dans un moment de de désescalade cela
dit je me fais aucune illusion je pense
qu'en tant d'ici deux trois mois comme
en avril 2021 on va nous rejouer le même
scénario et on ira encore droit à
l'automne 2022 donc voilà ça va être
cyclique ça va être cycliques pardon la
seule différence que je vois c'est d'une
part que l'économie ukrainienne est et
ça ça a été parfaitement 10 est dans un
bien pire état qu'elle ne l'était avant
cette crise d'après les chiffres que
j'ai vu ça lui a coûté 13 milliards et
demi à cause d'eux des banques run ce à
quoi auquel on a assisté et deuxièmement
à mon avis a comme un facteur nouveau et
intéressant c'est le chant cieux les
choletais qui a fait une excellente
prestation contrairement à celle de même
macron qui était vraiment mauvaise c'est
mon avis en tout cas c'est à dire qu'il
a parlé concrètement des accords de
minsk il a pas parlé de manière évasive
qu'il fallait appliquer les accords de
minsk il a parlé de que l'ukraine devait
prendre une loi qui donne l autonomie
aux dons de basse donc ça c'est un point
fondamental de l'accord de minsk et non
seulement il est dit à moscou mais il
l'a dit à kiev quand il était avec
zielinski contrairement à madame mâcon
qu'il en ai même pas parlé qui n'a même
pas parlé d'un simple échange de
prisonniers donc pour moi c'est les deux
éléments
très favorable à la russie c'est
l'économie ukrainienne continué à
s'effondrer donc à terme ça amènera
forcément un pouvoir alors s'ils sont
libérés de prison puisque les opposants
du président qui sont en prison ou en
exil actuellement mais s'ils sortent de
prison on pourrait très bien avoir un
parent un pouvoir pro-russe qui arrive
qui arrive à kiev dans d'ici un an d'ici
d'ici 2 ans et 2 et deuxièmement donc ce
point à mon avis qui est essentiel c'est
effectivement c'est également sur votre
chaîne d'ailleurs monsieur huchon qui
est un spécialiste de la maille m'avait
dit que scholtes pourrait pourrait nous
étonner et il l'a fait ce soir en tenant
un discours assez technique sur sur les
accords de minsk et puis en faisant bien
comprendre que l'enjeu énergétique
allemand ne serait pas victime de
desmenez qui viennent ou washingtonienne
vous voyez vous n'êtes pas tout à fait
d'accord c'est vrai que les allemands
ont des enjeux sur le gaz non pas les
français et bien sûr ils ont des enjeux
économiques mais je voudrais un petit
peu contre eux ce qui a été dit le duo
franco-allemand a très bien fonctionné
souvenons nous qu'en même que le
président macron y est allé il ya une
semaine c'est à dire en plein coeur dans
la crise il a commencé par aller à
moscou avant d'aller à kiev et de parler
de l'application des accords de minsk et
pardonnez moi mais il a bien parlé des
lois qui devait être passé par kiev sur
les zones de l'est de l'ukraine et le
président le pardon le chancelier jeu
georges lui est arrivé une semaine après
et a fait le trajet inverse c'est-à-dire
kiev moscou donc c'est un duo qui a très
bien fonctionné c'est le premier point
deuxième point je voudrais revenir sur
le mot vous avez employé qui est très
important c'est la confiance je crois
que c'est ça le problème le problème
c'est d'établir de la confiance pour
avoir la confiance il faut rétablir des
mesures de transparence comme elle
existait il ya 10 ou 15 ans lorsqu'on
avait mis en place les les modalités
d'inspection à l'est comme à l'ouest de
ciel ouvert et cetera qui permettent
d'établir la confiance parce que sinon
évidemment on repose sur des images
américaines d'un côté sur des images
russe de l'autre côté chacun cantonné
dans son coin et pouvant raconter des
des messages diamétralement opposées sur
une même situation pour de propagande du
côté américain tout de même on a vu la
presse anglo saxonne à laquelle a fait
référence régis le sommier on nous
annonçait ce matin dans le san que
l'invasion aura lieu à une heure du
matin les heures du matin mais non ce
qui est oui oui en effet
j'ai très bien avoir votre avis de
militaires là dessus et et régis soumier
vous qui connaissez bien aussi les etats
unis une stratégie anglo saxon et
notamment aidé par la presse qui joue un
rôle clairement mois moi je suis assez
terrifié de 2,2 ce que je vous de ce que
j'ai vu là parce que on en a on en a
parlé de justement de l'adedy prélude de
la guerre en irak on se souvient tous ou
même de la guerre en libye on se
souvient tous du moment où
l'intervention du point de vue de la
narration devient inéluctable ou 7 ce
souhait d'intervenir s'impose au monde
comme une solution absolue parce que que
ce soit kadhafi saddam hussein ces les
news les nouveaux hitler il on y voit là
ils ont changé et il faut absolument
sauver le monde là on a eu le même les
mêmes accents on a eu à nouveau un joe
biden qui est là aussi on peut quand
même raisonnablement se poser les
questions
que quand quand c'est le daily mail ou
quand ces quelques voilà un peu excité
et c'est avec une phobies antirusses
faut bien reconnaître chevillée au corps
depuis longtemps voilà que travers la
plume d'un journaliste d'un journaliste
où des informations de ces médias là on
peut comprendre que voilà on met ça
venait de la maison blanche aussi la
maison blanche a parlé de la date du 16
février annonçant qu'à l'aube
l'intervention allait commencer donc il
va chercher buy données de façon depuis
depuis un petit moment il peut se poser
des questions sur ce que fait le
président américain il a inutilement
provoqué un chaos en afghanistan en
précipitant un départ qui aurait très
bien pu se faire beaucoup plus en ordre
en d'abord respectant ses alliés en les
informant ce départ d'afghanistan ça a
été une catastrophe
ça a été d'abord le début de souvenez
vous on s'est dit le départ
d'afghanistan même trump à réagir c'est
à dire en bouffe on s'est débarrassé de
trump on a enfin présidence civilisé là
on l'a vu à l'oeuvre ensuite on l'a vu
humilié inutilement les français dans
l'histoire des sous-marins l'on peut
l'expliquer mais le fait de simplement
de deux se rendent compte que boris
johnson et joe biden sur un sommet
international qui est manuel macro et la
quittes savent que bientôt le comment et
ne prévienne n'est pas emmanuel macron
donc milliers inutilement donc à chaque
fois c'est inutile et là encore une fois
on fait une surenchère sur la guerre qui
est complètement inutile puisqu'il le
filet il n'y a pas de guerre en tout cas
pour l'instant il faut le souhaiter que
ça sera quand est ce que c'est vous
partager l'analyse de régis le sommier
ou voilà c'est une forme vous avez pas
dit de moi incompétence mais d'une
certaine manière où c'était finalement
une stratégie totalement voulue et
maîtrisée par washington avec d'ailleurs
l'aide des médias anglo saxons fait leur
maîtrise et je ne sais pas voulu
certainement quand je dis pas maîtrisés
c'est parce qu'il ya un emballement gelé
vécu aux états unis en 2002 2003 si vous
voulez vous avez un emballement et il ya
un moment où on peut plus dire le
contraire c'est pas possible on est dans
la voix je me souviens que je t'ai à la
mission française à l'époque et le
diplomate français qui négocier les
résolutions au conseil de sécurité me
disait j'étais colonel à l'époque c'est
mon colonel dites-moi quand ils
attaquent j'en peux plus parce que toute
façon c'est qu' il n'y a pas d'issue
c'est comme ça et donc on est dans cette
logique là c'est là où je pose la
question du résultat après alors il faut
attendre la fin des tensions d'ici une
semaine ou quinze jours mais quand on va
voir que la taxe n'a pas eu lieu le 16
alors que tout le monde jure et que ça
avait lieu le 16 qu'est ce que vont dire
les européens qui se sont fait prendre
une nouvelle fois dans le piège de
l'intoxication américaine qui avait été
la même au moment de l'irak
dans laquelle ils ont été abandonnés au
moment de l'afghanistan et dans lequel
aujourd'hui se sont fait prendre alors
il faut il faut bien faut bien tempéré
les choses c'est à dire que et c'est ce
que la france dit toujours nous sommes
des alliés de l'otan mais nous sommes à
vos amis et c'est pour ça qu'on peut
vous dire la vérité alors que les autres
sont pas toujours prêts à dire vous et
di mauro le gênait en traquant nous a
parlé de sang froid la france d'ailleurs
il faut quand même bien le dire est
resté plus calme que les états unis dans
cette affaire notamment ne serait-ce que
les déplacements de l'ambassade appelé
ses citoyens à fuir l'ukraine ce que n'a
pas fait la france c'est ce qu'a fait
les états unis je crois que la france
sonate en mi melle macron cas d élection
présidentielle dans deux mois il a bien
compris que déjà la russie n'avait
absolument pas l'intention d'envahir
d'envahir l'ukraine et que donc dans la
mesure où les choses allaient s'arranger
comme on l'a annoncé encore une fois sur
cette chaîne ya quelques semaines il
pourrait bénéficier de l'image du
diffuseur de paix dont qu'il a il a
plutôt bien joué à mon avis plutôt du
point de vue intérieure que du point de
vue des affaires internationales et en
revanche ce qu'il ne faut pas négliger
c'est l'idéologie il y à toute une
partie de l'établissement américain de
l'état bichonne français sous le quai
d'orsay en france est tenue par les
néoconservateurs c'est pas un secret qui
attendait dans bye donne le vengeur anti
poutine qu'ils allaient faire plier
poutine et qu'elle se à quoi ont ils
assisté en 2021 et bien un rapprochement
progressif de l'administration de biden
avec la russie il ya eu cette rencontre
qui a été accueillie avec horreur sur
cnn notamment par garry kasparov en
genève entre poutine et baden il ya eu
un défilé des représentants américains
burns le chef de la cia et victoriano
landes 8 blinken tous ont défilé à
moscou est donc en fait vous avez tout
cet establishment qui a une grosse
influence dans les médias américains est
aussi également dans les médias français
qui qui qui enrage de voir que baye
donne n'est pas le vengeur espérer mais
finalement peut-être celui qui va
continuer le plan de trump qui était de
ménager la russie pour pouvoir se
tourner vers la chine et donc il faut
pas sous-estimer cet aspect idéologie il
y a des gens alors pour une pour nous
quatre qui sommes des gens parfaitement
rationnel et qui avons une analyse
rationnelle ça nous concerne pas mais il
ya des gens dans les médias français et
surtout dans les médias anglo saxons qui
sont qui croient absolument à cet
affrontement civilisationnel
qu'ils soient encore dans l'est dans les
délires de brzezinski 10 10 à 30 ans
voilà donc donc il faut prendre ça en
compte et ça explique l'hystérie que
vous avez noté qui vous surprend
d'ailleurs je vous comprends en tant que
personne rationnelle que vous avez pu
observer dans les médias anglo saxons et
dans une partie des médias français
malheureusement enfin en tout cas tout
n'est pas réglé parce que moscou de son
côté 1 ne s'estime pas franchement
satisfaite puisque va dire poutine a
encore demandé aujourd'hui ces garanties
de sécurité il a répété ce qu'il a
toujours dit qu'on propose de l'écouter
et ligne voulons nous d'une guerre ou
pas bien sûr que non c'est pour cela
qu'on a avancé nos propositions pour un
processus de négociations
nous sommes prêts à continuer à
travailler ensemble nous sommes prêts à
nous engager sur la voie des
négociations mais tous les problèmes
comme indiqué précédemment doivent être
considéré comme un tout général traquant
on parle beaucoup de la vie de
l'occident la qui parle d' apaisement
mais enfin la russie n'a toujours pas eu
ces garanties de sécurité notamment sur
la fameuse extension de de l'otan alors
non mais vous avez raison bon
l'extension de l'otan je pense que ça va
pas être vraiment le sujet
du côté du oui mais je sais je connais
votre avis là-dessus c'est un sujet pour
la russe oui mais je répète que la
russie a eu tort de déposer un papier
sur la table c'est pas comme ça qu'on
commence une négociation on commence par
se réunir voir les points de vue des uns
et des autres et comment on peut bouger
parce qu'il faut arriver à un point de
vue commun ceci étant on est arrivé à un
maximum de tension ces tensions ont fait
qu'on doit venir avec des positions sur
la table dont le président poutine
d'ailleurs au passage a souligné que
certaines propositions du président
macron était intéressante et à retenir
donc ce qu'il faut c'est pas laisser
retomber ça et pas revenir comme cela
était et c'est un risque que au
printemps prochain on revienne à une
autre période de tensions il faut
absolument exploiter dans la foulée que
tant que le faire est chaud comme on dit
de façon à pouvoir recréer les mesures
de confiance qui prendront une partie de
ce que la russie veut une partie de ce
que l'otan ou l'ouest veut mais en tout
état de cause qu on arrive à une vraie
négociation ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui c'est une évidence ce sommet
de toute façon le chancelier allemand et
président de ce monde où les
négociations vont se poursuivre à vous
parler du printemps prochain mais enfin
la sphère n'est pas réglé à ce jour non
l' affaire n'est pas réglé puisque le
pré le fameux le point principal
finalement 2-2 d'affrontements ou enfin
soulevé par les russes c'est la question
justement d'empêcher d'avoir des
garanties d'ailleurs c'est très
intéressant de la façon dont les dents
les russes quand on regarde au niveau du
vocabulaire quand il parle de cette
crise il parle d'un dialogue de sécurité
donc c'est le mot sécurité qui tient qui
est important fondamentale il n'y a pas
de bulle il n'ya pas l'ukraine là dedans
rennes est un texte ce qu'a d'ailleurs
cela ressemblait saisir emmanuel macron
l'idée la perspective d'un règlement
global je pense que c'est ce que les
russes voudrait parvenir à imposer ou en
tout cas à ce qui est l'accord tourne
autour de ça et l'idée étant pour eux
viscéralement que l'otan ne soit pas à
leurs frontières ce qui est quand même
une quelque chose qui peut apparaître
quand même comme légitime quand on quand
on regarde ce qui s'est passé en quarts
en 86 comment ronald reagan pour
prométhéa gorbatchev que l'otan ne
s'attendrait pas à l'est en réalité
aujourd'hui nos troupes sont déployés on
le voit on voit bien le nom année on a
une présence française en estonie en
roumanie les américains vont proposer un
contingent de 3 3 millions en pologne
ils ont rapatrié d'ailleurs en
perspective une invasion supposer leur
186 militaire d'ukraine tout simplement
pourquoi parce que l'ukraine ne fait pas
partie de l'otan donc si l'ukraine est
attaqué l'otan ne va pas en revanche ces
autres pays là dans lesquels sont
disposés des troupes ce sont des troupes
qui sont là pour dire si vous envahissez
l'estonie la roumanie ou la pologne eh
bien vous vous vous mettez dans une
situation où vous allez tuer des
français des anglais des allemands ou
voilà et c'est ça l'aspect défensif du
principe de l'otan mais là donc la
russie ce qu'elle demande c'est
justement de ne pas voir à ses
frontières l'alliance à 30 atlantique
là pour le moment on a entendu le
président alain ski dire que ça ne se
serait pas le cas en revanche il ya son
ambassadeur à londres qui a eu des
propos un peu moins un peu plus en
milieu et du coup qui a dû corriger ça
parce que ça c'est le problème de fond
et si ça s'est résolu on parle de
finlandisation de l'ukraine il ya des
termes qui sont utilisés de façon à ce
que chacun puisse faire un pas et qu' on
n'arrive pas à un conflit l'idée c'est
d'arriver à ce que ces conflits
éternelle qui existe depuis 20 ans
comment dans le monde les interventions
occidentales où ces gros conflit ne se
produisent pas en ukraine l'ukraine ça
fait presque partie de l'europe on n'a
pas envie que ça devienne un champ de
bataille extrêmement rapidement parce
qu'il y avait un autre développement
aujourd'hui général train quand la
reconnaissance des territoires
séparatistes serait une agression sans
arme avertit paris ça c'est encore un
pont un autre pendu du conflit
c'est l'opposé des accords de minsk sa
part c'est l'opposé des temps de vie
c'est le président poutine le président
macron le chancelier 10 pour revenir à
l'accord de minsk la corde domine c'est
quoi c'est un statut spécial pour les
régions de l'ouest mais au sein de
l'ukraine donc pas une reconnaissance
comme l'est par exemple la transnistrie
que tout le monde a oublié sur la
frontière moldave donc c'est important
de revenir à l'accord de minsk pour
maintenir les frontières qui t'a dit
qu'elles sont mais donner une plus
grande liberté à cette population
russophone qui est dans l'est de
l'ukraine il faut préciser que peuvent
la meilleure poutine a dit
qu'aujourd'hui que cette reconnaissance
de l'indépendance de ces deux n'était
pas d'actualité donc voila merci merci
de préciser effectivement merci régis le
sommier merci générale 5 ans et à vous
aussi merci xavier moreau pour ce
décryptage
et dans le reste de l'actualité dans le
monde la contestation anti restrictions
sanitaires au canada qui ne cesse de
faire parler d'elle ce soir le chef de
la police d'ottawa a démissionné un
départ alors que le convoi de la liberté
bloquent toujours les rues du centre
ville de son côté justin trudeau est
décidé à en finir avec ce mouvement qui
dure depuis deux semaines le premier
ministre canadien qui a recours depuis
ce lundi à la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence margot du lard
un événement exceptionnel mesures
exceptionnelles
après avoir dégagé de force les
manifestants qui bloquaient le pont
ambassador le premier ministre du canada
justin trudeau annonce le recours à la
loi sur les mesures d'urgence c'est la
deuxième fois seulement que cette
disposition est mise en place en temps
de paix la police au big evan morte
source
la police disposera de plus d'outils
pour rétablir l'ordre dans les lieux où
les assemblées publiques peuvent
constituer des activités illégales et
dangereuses comme les barrages et les
occupations à ottawa au pont ambassador
et ailleurs ces outils comprennent le
renforcement de leur capacité de donner
des amendes ou des peines
d'emprisonnement
le gouvernement désignera sécurisera et
protégera les endroits et les
infrastructures essentielles à notre
économie aux emplois des canadiens y
compris les postes frontaliers et les
aéroports nous ne pouvons pas nous ne
permettrons pas que des activités
illégales et dangereuses se poursuivre
dans des camps
cette mesure d'urgence entre en vigueur
immédiatement
et bien qu'elle concerne l'ensemble du
pays elle n'aura d'impact concret que
dans certaines régions comme en ontario
où se trouve ottawa la capitale
paralysée
le mouvement des convois de la liberté
débuté fin janvier et petit à petit
devenu un mouvement large de refus de
l'ensemble des mesures sanitaires suite
à la décision du premier ministre les
manifestants ont réuni leurs forces pour
continuer la contestation je suis venu
la première semaine je suis rentré chez
moi j'ai regardé les infos et j'ai
entendu trudeau mentir il a menti et ça
m'a tellement content arie que j'ai
quitté mon travail et je suis revenu ici
et je resterai là jusqu'à ce que nous
gagnons et m confuse moi je suis confus
what is because
tout d'abord au sujet de ce que trudeau
outil parce que vous savez quoi nous
voulons seulement une chose
finir avec ces confinement et avec ces
restrictions
nous n'avons aucun intérêt politique
dans cette action en fait je m'en fiche
de ce qu'il faut parlement nous voulons
retrouver nos libertés
première victoire à souligner cependant
pour les manifestants le premier
ministre de l'ontario doug ford a
annoncé hier que dès le 1er mars le pass
vaccinale seraient suspendues dans
l'ensemble de la province
convoi de la liberté canadien qui s'est
exporté en france après paris et
bruxelles quelques dizaines demande du
convoi ont qui passent sont réunis
aujourd'hui devant le parlement européen
de strasbourg une protestation
organisées malgré l'interdiction
préfectorale de toute manifestation dans
la capitale alsacienne selon les
protestataires présents le pass
vaccinale pose question sur les libertés
de chacun il reproche au gouvernement de
l'avoir introduit sans consentement on
les écoute
aujourd'hui on n'empêche que le peuple
puisse rencontrer ses représentants
aujourd'hui on aime poignée ici
politiques représentatives composé de ce
qui se passe et des gens qui pensent
tous les métiers possibles ils ont voulu
pouvoir pour crier et demander justice
parce qu'aujourd'hui la justice n'a pas
par les expulsions et les tribunaux ont
la part des gens qui représentent le
propre compte nous avons décidé après
concertation de venir ici pour porter la
parole de tous les collectifs ce pompier
soignants médico sociaux enseignants
parents étudiants et citoyens qui
souhaitent justement
dire leur fatigue leur mécontentement
face à des mesures qu'elles soient
sanitaires aux politiques qui ont été
prises en leur nom ces dernières années
sans leur consentement alors nous tous
les mouvements citoyens évidemment les
écoute parce que c'est important d'avoir
le contact avec des citoyens et puis
surtout celui-là qui porte une
revendication qui nous apparaît quand
même assez légitime sur le défense des
libertés et au grand dam de ses
convoyeurs de la liberté les conditions
d'obtention du pasp et finales se
durcissent aujourd'hui en france plus de
4 millions de français sont susceptibles
de voir leur sésame annulée en raison du
passage de six à quatre mois du délai
maximal autorisé entre la réalisation la
dernière dose et le rappelle on en parle
avec notre reporter david kelly faa
proximité du ministère de la santé
bonsoir david les conditions donc se
durcissent pour les non vaccinés mais
pour les retardataires il ya quand même
une exception de dernière minute qui a
été annoncée ce matin par le
gouvernement dans sa grande bonté
effectivement stéphanie un peu de rab
pour ceux qui ont réalisé à leur dose de
rappel il ya moins de sept jours ces
personnes ne verront pas leurs passes
annulés aujourd'hui comme cela aurait dû
être le cas puisque vous le savez il
faut un délai d'une semaine après sa
dose de rappel pour que cette dernière
soit valide pour les autres en revanche
si vous n'avez pas été exposés au virus
par le vaccin ou la contamination il y a
à moins de quatre mois et bien vous
perdez votre pass vaccinale un
dispositif mis en place par l'exécutif
une fois de plus pour inciter à la
vaccination et faire face à la flambée
du variant omicron quelques exceptions
pour ceux qui ne peuvent pas être
vaccinés pour raisons médicales un
certificat de contre indication à la
vaccination reste valable pour accéder
aux lieux et activités ou le pass
vaccinale est exigé qu'ils sont toujours
les mêmes d'ailleurs les -18 ans eux ne
sont pas concernés par ces mesures est
dernier point si vous débutez votre
schéma vaccinal est l'injection d'une
première dose peut donner accès à une
phase à une impasse vaccinale temporaire
à condition de recevoir sa deuxième dose
dans un délai de quatre semaines et de
présenter un test négatif de moins de 24
heures et david dès demain les
discothèques vont pouvoir prouver
rouvrir leurs portes après deux mois de
fermeture vous êtes déjà dans les
starting blocks
ouais alors le gouvernement poursuit à
l'allègement de ces restrictions je sais
pas si moi je suis dans les starting
blocks en tout cas ça va faire beaucoup
d'heureux 1 ce qui m est les pistes de
danse 1 fermé depuis le décembre est
particulièrement malmenées depuis le
début de la pandémie les discothèques
pourront rouvrir demain et les concerts
debout reprendront également mais il
faudra continuer à montrer patte blanche
évidemment pour pouvoir y accéder vous
pourrez aussi consommer de boue
notamment dans les bars les stades et
cinémas lé prochaine étape c'est la fin
du port du masque obligatoire dans les
lieux soumis aux passes vaccinale sauf
dans les transports une levée des
restrictions dues à une baisse notable
de 440 2253 cas ces dernières 24 heures
mais la situation sanitaire reste tout
de même fragile fragile a notamment dans
l'est dans les hôpitaux avec plus de 31
mille patients avec le co vide 19 et
plus de 3300 patients dans les services
de réanimation le porte parole du
gouvernement préfère rester vigilant
il ya des pays où nombre assez limité
mais des pays quand même qui ont fait le
choix de tous levés d'un coup très vite
dans lesquels on constate une reprise
très forte de l'épidémie donc si on est
amené à prendre des décisions
d'allègement supplémentaires au delà de
celles que nous avons annoncés c'est à
dire demain pour les ultimes
restrictions qui touchent les
établissements recevant du public du
public la semaine prochaine pour les
écoles et la suivante pour le masque en
intérieur dans les lieux soumis aux
passes sanitaire si on est amené à
prendre d'autres décisions plus tard
quelques semaines plus tard c'est parce
que nous aurons considéré et parce que
les autorités de santé nous aurons dit
on peut le faire au regard de la
situation sanitaire
et puis concernant la fin du pass
vaccinale vous le savez le gouvernement
l'envisagent pour fin mars ou début
avril mais là encore cela dépendra de
l'évolution sanitaire en tout cas comme
je vous le disais les amoureux du
dancefloor pourront se déchaîner demain
soir une bonne nouvelle à merci merci
david kelly faille pour en parler nous
sommes avec alexis poulain
éditorialistes rt france et c'est notre
rubrique l'édito
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain les d'accord pour
ouvrir alors avant de vous précipiter
dessus vous restez avec nous quelques
minutes aujourd'hui près de 4 millions
de français vaccinés vont perdre leur
pass vaccinale 1 faute de rappel il ya
eu un petit point de communication du
gouvernement oui c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire je crois que plus personne
ne comprend ces mesures à la fois une
injection qui vaut une infection une
affection qui vaut une injection le 15
février c'était dans la tête de personne
en réalité les gens n'ont pas vu cette
date arriver donc ils n'ont pas anticipé
la troisième dose ou la dose puisqu'il
faut une dose peu importe le nombre
d'infections et puis on ne sait plus
finalement on parle de mesure levée en
réalité non les mesures sont toujours là
on ne les comprend pas le pass vaccinale
commence à peser très lourd et puis je
voudrais ce soir penser à tous ceux qui
ont perdu leur travail qui ont été
soumis à cette obligation vaccinale les
soignants les ambulanciers les pompiers
qui eux sont sans emploi depuis des mois
et puis ces millions de français qui
sont désactivés d'un jour à l'autre
parce qu'ils n'ont pas la dose qu'il
faut alors que les études commencent à
arriver pour dire avec au micron la
troisième dose ne sert quasiment à rien
pour les moins de 60 ans enfin en terme
de bénéfice risque du moins et puis je
ne vois pas comment le gouvernement peut
continuer avec ce pass vaccinale sachant
que ckoi 45% de la population qui n'a
pas la troisième dose donc entre les
infections peut-être qu'on va arriver à
se raccrocher aux branches mais c'est
plus de 10 millions de français voire
beaucoup plus qui aujourd'hui risquent
de ne pas avoir de passes travail à
quelques grogne quand même parmi eux des
sénateurs et l'eire qui appelle à la
levée immédiate du pass vaccinale est ce
que c'est possible c'est tout à fait
possible compte tenu aujourd'hui des
chiffres de la drees et puis il n'y a
pas d'embouteillage dans les hôpitaux
contrairement à ce que dit gabriela
talent dans un cas classique mais
le coc vide n'est plus ce qu'il a été
les pics qu'on a connu auparavant ce
qu'on voit c'est que c'est devenu un
objet politique regardez au canada ce
qui s'est passé avec les convois de
liberté on n'a plus le droit de dire
qu'il faut lever le passé pourtant la
lutte a payé puisque le québec va lever
le passe en france c'est pareil pourquoi
les sénateurs et leers insee de tribunes
et on peut les remercier c'est parce que
emmanuel macron va utiliser la levée du
pass comme un outil politique dans sa
campagne pour dire qu'il a vaincu lcos
vide alors qu'il n'en est rien
aujourd'hui on sait que les commandes de
vaccins s'arrête mais elles reprennent
en mai donc en fait c'est simplement un
moratoire le temps de la campagne pour
faire croire que le comider derrière
nous grâce à emmanuel macron avec en
plus cette levée du pass vaccinale qui
est un pasa trou puisque vacciner on
peut contaminer donc il ya nécessité de
lever le pass dès à présent on voit
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui se passe en
grande-bretagne aux pays-bas au danemark
où tout est levée pourquoi vouloir
continuer absolument en france alors que
en réalité aucune mesure n'a jusqu'à
présent juguler l'épidémie de covin si
ce n'est au micron qui permet à tous
finalement d'avoir locaux vides sans
aller forcément en réanimation alors
autant les convois de la liberté ont
plutôt été mis en échec pour l'instant
en france quelles suites possibles la
suite possible ça va être la
désobéissance je pense ou le refus de
continuer à jouer au jeu du pass à
savoir si c'est un numéro impair où
percent il faut une troisième une
quatrième dose on l'a déjà vu la fatigue
des français par rapport à la troisième
dose beaucoup ont traîné des pieds pour
y aller très peu finalement 45% je le
disais donc ce qui reste vu la la la la
le dispositif policier a été mis en
place contre les convois de la liberté à
paris mais aussi à bruxelles et puis on
voit la faible mobilisation a
malheureusement on peut le regretter
mais se battre pour les libertés
finalement c'est pas quelque chose qui
intéresse et qui agrège donc comment
continuer et puis si on continue si on
regarde ces convois de la liberté le
problème c'est que au canada maintenant
justin trudeau n'a pas honte de demander
à avoir des sanctions financières sur
les gens qui ont supporté financièrement
ces convois de la liberté en disant que
voilà les banques vont pouvoir geler les
avoirs des gens qui ont donné à la
cagnotte et c'est donc ce sera je pense
un retour à la vie normale sans passe
pour une majorité de français qui vont
arrêter de jouer à ce je n'arrive plus à
comprendre en fait les règles changent
trop souvent et puis maintenant je crois
que tout le monde a envie de tourner la
page qu'ovide même si il est toujours
avec nous merci alexis poulain pour
votre édito et pour la première fois un
novak djokovic bien reconnaît ne pas
être vaccinés ne pas être anti vaccins
non plus le numéro un mondial de tennis
sort de son silence aujourd'hui accordé
une interview à nos confrères de la bbc
le joueur serbe revient sur son éviction
de l'open d'australie premier tournoi
majeur de l'année il précise également
être prêt à renoncer à d'autres tournois
du grand chelem plutôt que de se faire
vacciner
je n'ai jamais été contre la vaccination
je comprends que dans le monde on essaie
de faire de gros efforts pour gérer ce
virus mais j'ai toujours soutenu la
liberté de choisir ce que vous mettez
dans votre corps je comprends les
critiques je comprends que les gens et
sorties différentes théories sur la
chance que j'ai eue d'avoir le coc vide
en décembre ou à quel point c'était
pratique mais personne n'est chanceux ou
trouve sa pratique d'attraper locaux
vides je prends cela très au sérieux
j'étais vraiment triste et déçu de la
façon dont ça s'est terminé pour moi en
australie
et à l'instar de plusieurs pays
européens angleterre poursuit l'abandon
de nouvelles restrictions tiko vide par
les stones sun envisage de mettre un
terme à l' isolement obligatoire des cas
positifs d'ici fin février alors que la
loi est fixé jusqu'au 24 mars prochain
pour être abrogés dès le 21 février soit
un mois d'avancé sur le calendrier
initial
le premier ministre britannique souhaite
présenter aux parlementaires une
stratégie pour vivre avec le co vide et
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis baisse au royaume uni avec abba
tapant cagna expert en maladies
infectieuses à l'université d'exeter
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir baratte up au kenya merci d'être
avec nous des restrictions 1 depuis le
27 janvier plus de port du masque en
tout cas pas obligatoire télétravail qui
n'est plus officiellement recommandé le
pass annie terre qui n'est plus imposées
à l'accès aux boîtes de nuit ces
nouveaux allègements sont ils pour vous
des décisions politiques où sont-ils
vraiment justifiée par la situation
sanitaire
je pense qu'il ya un peu de
sang neuf à quatorze le souligne me
connaissais pas johnny des conseils qui
ont été données au premier ministre
boris kenza d'or
mais les indicateurs montrent que le
royaume uni se remet d
de l'important nombre de cadres qu'il a
subi malheureusement des gens meurent
encore mais en général pour le moment le
royaume uni est en passe de se remettre
de l'explosion des cas alors la dernière
mesure en vigueur tout de même
d'isolement des cas positifs qui
pourrait bien sauter bien plus tôt que
prévu c'est en tout cas le souhait de
boris johnson qu'en pense
l'épidémiologiste que vous êtes
match con sen
très préoccupant pour nous il fallait
être contaminées sans avoir besoin de
s'isoler cela signifie qu'on peut sortir
de chez soi qu'on peut rencontrer
d'autres personnes et qu'au pire et donc
contaminés gravement d'autres personnes
harry caine deux
épidémies en tant qu'idéologie ces
experts les maladies infectieuses je
vous conseille si vous êtes malade si
vous êtes contaminé de ne pas sortir de
ne pas risquer de contaminer d'autres
personnes il vaut bien mieux rester chez
soi plutôt que sortir même si le
gouvernement dit que c'est possible
beaucoup d'observateurs en tout cas
n'ont pas manqué de reprocher ses
décisions boris johnson pour des raisons
plus politiques on sait que le premier
ministre britannique est empêtré dans
son scandale du du parti gates est
pourtant une stratégie qui s'avère
payante au royaume uni leur monde un
petit peu en popularité malgré tout
la popularité restera toujours
temporaire wild side car on ne peut pas
tricher avec la science maintien si la
science carrefour si l'on passe rue dose
et orange
pourra causer des maladies cela pourra
déboucher sur des décès y aura donc les
indicateurs montrent qu'il reste prudent
même si le gouvernement dit qu'il est
temps d'abandonner les restrictions il
abandonner les règles je conseille en
tant qu'expert des maladies infectieuses
d'être très prudente tout d'abord il
fera ensuite de ne pas risquer de
contaminer d'autres personnes
s'ils ont contaminé de rester chez soi
puis dans les 4 par exemple des ehpad
les hôpitaux par exemple contente
d'affirmer il faut être suffisamment
prudent et continuer à porter le masque
aujourd'hui en france les restrictions
s'allège aussi ça sera le cas à partir
de demain mais dans le même temps les
conditions d'obtention du pass vaccinale
se durcissent en a réduit le délai entre
les doses de rappel est ce que en tant
que spécialiste de la question c'est une
décision qui vous paraît justifié
aujourd'hui
le buste options and protect you le
rappel vaccinal protège l'individu
c'est un choix personnel plutôt qu'un
choix publics
il fait que en général mon avis d'expert
we have enough vac sûr est que
maintenant nous avons assez de doses
pour vacciner le monde entier les autres
glings que de
bonnes choses que l'intérieur est ici de
se faire vacciner de quoi il se rappelle
tous les jours je vois des personnes
en bonne santé et très contaminés mais
et développer des formes graves de la
maladie la pure bruce se prendre ce
rappel c'est une façon de l'éviter
dernière petite question après chypre
c'est au tour du royaume uni chez vous
donc de signaler un premier cas du delta
kron alors cette forme hybride des
variants deltalyo micron il a été classé
dans la liste des mutations sont
surveillance vous pouvez nous en dire
plus combien de cas est ce que cela vous
paraît de nature dangereuse
on ne sait pas à ce stade ici ce variant
et quand je repose mais cela est encore
une fois un exemple du fait que de
nouveaux variants préoccupant ils
continueront d'arriver et cela peut être
un pas dans la mauvaise direction et
c'est à dire qu'il pourrait plus
contourner l'efficacité des vaccins
contourner les défenses immunitaires de
2 me la chose la plus important ce que
ça lui est donc d'éviter les cas une
monde antique ice us sinon on diminue le
nombre de cas alors on espère et
j'insiste on espère qu'il y aura moins
de variants préoccupant qui peuvent
apparaître dans toutes les régions du
monde merci marathon kenya d'avoir été
avec nous pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir
reste avec mon dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de l' échange
téléphonique entre eric mouri donald
trump pendant 40 minutes le canadien le
candidat à la présidentielle française
s'est entretenu avec l'ancien chef de
l'état américain coup de pouce ou coup
d'épée dans l'eau zemmour train même
combat le débat est ouvert
[Musique]
le joueur de tennis numéro un mondial
sanctionnée pour ne pas avoir fourni de
preuves de vaccination anti qu'ovide
c'est une affaire sportive mais c'est
une affaire politique et également pour
lui c'est une bataille qui va au delà du
problème de vaccination il a préféré se
sacrifier pour pouvoir être du côté des
gens qui disent qu'il faut en terminer
avec les contraintes il faut savoir que
c'est quelqu'un qui vient du kosovo qui
se souvient très bien des bombardements
de l'otan sur la serbie et le kosovo en
99 et donc pour lui c'est la bataille du
canda liberté contre le camp de pression
dans quel état d'esprit sont les
australiens après cette affaire son cas
divise et l'australie il faut comprendre
que les australiens ils ont vécu ici
deux ans très très compliqué où les
frontières étaient fermés il ya beaucoup
de monde qui était choqué quand c'était
annoncé que nos vertes sans vaccin de
venir
[Musique]
quels sont les sujets qui ont fait
l'actualité économique des derniers
jours tout d'abord la dette américaine
je suis pas d'accord pour crier au loup
sur la dette publique
tout simplement parce que quand la dette
publique arrive à échéance l'état peut
toujours et emprunter la question étant
de savoir quel temps la dette c'est de
l'impôt futur c'est un moment on vous
apportera la note quoi qu'il arrive donc
on peut pas dire on s'en fout toutes les
banques centrales et c'est un de juguler
l'inflation pendant que christine
lagarde a qui est plutôt optimiste et je
dis souvent que j'aimerai pas être un
banquier central en ce moment pour une
raison simple c'est que vous ne disposez
pas en tant que banque centrale des
instruments qui sont nécessaires à
juguler l'inflation on a aujourd'hui
c'est du discours c'est de la com
attendez que le marché est un peu secoué
et vous verrez les banquiers centraux
revenir ventre à terre en disant ah
maintenant on est désolé on revêt ce les
taux
[Musique]
m
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres c'est le silence qui parle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlogs
l'isolent de la société
le new york times
le washington post
der spiegel
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçus
mais pas surpris
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire l'échangé téléphonique entre
eric zemmour et donald trump coup de
pouce ou coup d'épée dans l'eau pendant
quarante minutes les candidats à la
présidentielle française s'est entretenu
avec l'ancien président américain
selon le parti la reconquête donald
trump a conseillé aux polémistes de
tenir bon notamment face aux médias
alors le milliardaire peut-il vraiment
considéré eric zemmour comme un nouvel
allié zemmour trump même combat le débat
sera ouvert dans quelques instants
[Musique]
l'équipe de campagne d'eric zemmour se
félicitant de l'entretien téléphonique
du candidat avec donald trump eric
zemmour revendique une proximité avec
l'ancien président républicain elle les
deux hommes ont notamment échangé sur
leurs idéologies on en parle avec elle
notre correspondant à washington thomas
bonnet f bonsoir thomas alors qu'est ce
que se sont dit eric zemmour et donald
trump bonsoir stéphanie
et bien finalement on sait assez peu de
choses de cet échange qui nous dit on a
duré une quarantaine de minutes entre
donald trump et eric zemmour les équipes
du candidat à la présidentielle
française communicants donnant trois
thèmes majeurs de leurs discussions
immigration sécurité et économie on y
apprend aussi que les deux hommes
auraient surtout échanger sur les
recettes du succès de donald trump lors
de l'élection présidentielle de 2016
l'ancien président qui aurait ainsi
prodigué des conseils aux candidats à la
présidentielle en france écoutez
j'ai discuté avec donald trump pendant
une demi heure on va discuter de nos
campagnes respectives les leçons qu'on
en tire est il m'a dit de rester moi
même que les médias allaient me qualifie
de brutal mais que je devais être
sincère et que l'important est de garder
la sincérité et je pense qu'il a raison
les équipes d'eric zemmour résume les
changes ainsi donald trump souhaite que
les états unis restent les états unis et
eric zemmour souhaite que la france
reste la france alors évidemment il ya
une proximité idéologique entre les deux
hommes on peut aussi mettre en parallèle
l'aspect du candidat outsider anti
système qui était qui est cultivée par
eric zemmour et qui avait déjà été
cultivée de la même manière par donald
trump lors de la campagne de 2016 mais
il ya aussi beaucoup de divergences
entre les deux hommes on sait notamment
qu'eric zemmour n'est pas franchement
atlantiste alors évidemment pour eric
zemmour cet appel permet de cultiver un
aspect présidentiable mais il faut
toutefois souligner qu'il n'y a eu
aucune communication officielle de la
part de donald trump ou de ses équipes
pas de soutien affiché publiquement il
ya même eu un verbatim rapporté par des
médias tels que le parisien elle des
propos attribués donc à donald trump à
l'issue de son entretien avec eric
zemmour je vaux le site macro is the
night gaye macron est un homme sympa
voilà qui permet de relativiser
peut-être l'importance accordée à cet
entretien entre eric zemmour et donald
trump évidemment on rappellera qu'en
2017 marine le pen s'était rendu à la
trump tower à new york alors que donald
trump venait d'être élu à la maison
blanche mais elle n'avait pas eu la
possibilité de le rencontrer puis en
2010 est toujours barack obama qui avait
lui déjà quitté la maison blanche avait
apporté son soutient publiquement à
emmanuel macron merci thomas bonnin en
direct de washington alors cet échange
par téléphone entre eric zemmour et
donald trump est ce un coup pouce sont
bien un coup d'épée dans l'eau on attend
vos réactions sur le conte télégramme
d'ayrté france et place maintenant à
notre débat
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler ce soir
philippe karsenty porte-parole de droite
pour la france soutien d'eric zemmour
est membre du parti l'est républicain
ancien maire adjoint de
neuilly-sur-seine bonsoir philippe
karsenty merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés valérie de bord oratrice de la
cellule riposte de valérie pécresse
candidate dont évidemment à valérie
pécresse les républicains à la
présidentielle 2022 bonsoir à vous et
merci d'être là philippe karsenty c'est
une véritable étape dans la campagne
d'eric zemmour ce coup de fil très
médiatisée entre donald trump est
lui-même c'est une étape supplémentaire
savez j'étais porte parole de donald
trump en france lors de la dernière
campagne présidentielle américaine porte
parole du parti républicain américain
aussi je reste donc membre de l air
malgré tout je vote eric zemmour j'ai
choisi regza moore
c'est une évolution naturelle
les gens de notre équipe nous avons tous
beaucoup de respect pour valérie
pécresse
simplement on pense que ça n'est pas la
bonne candidate et on pense
qu'aujourd'hui
vous savez je m'amuse souvent parce que
j'ai entendu eric zemmour parler de
valérie pécresse comme la candidate de
20h02 et moi j'ai envie de dire j'ai
l'impression que les élèves vont plutôt
être les 20 02 c'est à dire les 20
février je pense que dimanche prochain
quand les gens de l air vont voir les
résultats des sondages et vont
comprendre à quel point il ya un crash
dimanche dernier je pense que les
basculement vers eric zemmour vont être
assez importe c'est vrai qu'à vous même
vous pourriez faire l'objet d'un débat
effectivement cette porosité entre les
républicains et le parti recomptait
inquiète en tout cas eric zemmour alors
ce soir c'est vrai qu'on va se
concentrer même si on va parler d'un
dernier sondage qui est paru ce soir
évidemment à la fin de ce débat mais
enfin va se concentrer sur ce coup de
fil vous valérie de mort quel regard
vous portez sur cet échange entre
l'ancien président américain et eric
zemmour au sein des des républicains
parce que c'est vrai que ce n'est pas
rien ça dit quelque chose
qui pour moi
donald trump suis quelqu'un d'assez peu
bien élevé qui ait un rapport aux femmes
assez exécrable qui aujourd'hui est sous
le coup d'une procédure par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé au capitole tu passes
certaine ce soit un exemple de
démocratie
aujourd'hui pour notre pays et
notre interlocuteur aujourd'hui lui même
sur fox news s'est fait couper la parole
parce qu'il estimait que l'attentât à
notre dame était un complot donc je
crois qu'on est un peu dans un autre
monde qui est le monde des gens qui
croient qu'il ya des complots partout
qui les agite un petit peu de toutes
parts et qui aujourd'hui 100 ans
s'ennorgueillit sme je ne suis pas
certaine que ce soit le climat
nécessaire pour la france et je ne suis
pas certaine que c'est ce que souhaitent
les français donc
franchement un tout petit épiphénomène
ses cartons un plan pour rappeler une
chose vous avez parlé d'attentât de
notre dame j'ai jamais dit qu'il y avait
un attentat c'est vous qui le dites je
dis simplement que je l'étais on ou non
vous avez parlé d'attentât avait dit il
y avait un attentat à notre dame c'est
un complot je n'ai jamais dit qu'ils
avaient un complot j'ai simplement dit
quand les médias ont tous dit
unanimement on sait déjà que c'est un
accident est pas un acte criminel j'ai
dit alors qu'elle l'église est encore
temps brûlé j'ai tout simplement dit
attendons de voir les résultats et vous
avez vous même parlé d'attentât moi je
n'ai pas encore parlé d'attentât non
monsieur vous avez très précisément dit
c'est notre 11 novembre à l'eau c'est à
ce moment là la bleue ou non le 11
novembre vous trompez c'est l'ensemble
en novembre c'est l'armistice en
septembre excusez-moi nécessaire de
parler d'attentât selon les goûts mais
c'est à ce moment là que le journaliste
de fox news qui est plutôt une chaîne
proche de monsieur tram faut vous ce que
j'en sais je connais c'est bizarre non
mais vous attraper sincèrement vous un
bandeau camp nou sé té des propos que
vous ne pouviez pas allégué de cette
façon et que si vous aviez des
informations il fallait les données ou
alors il fallait vous taire les sifflets
votre propre au seul à dire en tout cas
ce soir chez les républicains du côté de
valérie pécresse en gros donald rheault
n'est pas très crédible mais votre n'est
pas la personnalité centre et l'adorable
il n'est pas très crédible valérie de
mort alors je me reprends pour vous
aujourd'hui c'est de dire si on se fie
bien votre idée
donald trump n'est pas quelqu'un de
fréquentable et finalement c'est plutôt
contreproductif pour eric zemmour c'est
ce que vous nous dites avant de repasser
la part leur moi ce que je vous dis
c'est qu'aujourd'hui monsieur donald
trump est sous le coup d'une procédure
de la part du congrès américain par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé au capitole
ça c'est une réalité que c'est aussi
quelqu'un qui a tenu des propos qui sont
quand même aux confins du machisme et de
l'impolitesse
donc voilà après si c'est un modèle pour
monsieur zemmour mais qu'ils l'assument
c'est vrai que lui même a tient des
propos mis à vis des femmes qui sont
particulièrement misogyne donc je vais
vous comprendrez ce niveau là jusqu'à
resserrement des dépenses c'est moi ce
qui m'ennuie c'est que je reste un
membre et l'air et je me souviens que le
dernier président ait l'air c'est
nicolas sarkozy et nicolas sarkozy il
n'est pas seulement sous le coup de la
justice me lahaie 2-4-2 condamnation à
de la prison ferme ça c'est quand même
quelque chose d'étonnant et fin quand je
pense qu'on n'ose critiquer donald trump
quand on sait qui on a en france et qui
ont eu comme président a l'air c'est
quand même incroyable donc je
franchement rester sur votre ligne
arrêtez d'attaquer uniquement sur les
personnes on a simplement un président
donald trump qui était vraiment je
dirais sur la ligne politique de la
droite française exactement sursis
politique et ce qu'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est que malheureusement à
l'époque lr a soutenu le parti démocrate
regardez ce qu'est le parti démocrate
vous savez je vais vous dire une chose
valérie pécresse ne fera probablement
pas mieux café hillary clinton elle
continuera à jouer la carte du
soi-disant du mit de la misogynie etc
c'est ridicule elle s'est crashée en
direct c'est une femme qui est
respectable mais qui s'est crashé en
direct devant tout le monde aujourd'hui
vous êtes encore là moi je pense que le
20 février vous serez peut-être déjà
chez emmanuel macron en tout cas mon ami
de bord la réponse
moi j'aime bien en fait les sept espèces
de thons incantatoire d'un monsieur qui
écrit quand même des livres avec renaud
camus oui j'assume parallèlement il
s'appelle gauche en t'attendant qui
s'achève en 2010 cette dernière chanson
la grand-place mois 7,7 dans la
publicité on est très bien de quelqu'un
aussi qu' effectivement tient des propos
parfaitement complotistes pas si vous
voulez vous dites monsieur x a créé dix
ans de conflit
un placement est une réalité sortez
sortez de votre sortie de vous une
petite idée
même valérie pécresse en parle vous êtes
non valérie pécresse a dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de grands plats ne l a dit
mais vous dites nous renvoie dans l'eau
des mémoires 560 me fait de la peine
parce que c'est ma famille politique et
vous savez ce qui est étonnant monsieur
mais vraiment très étonnant qui est
d'ailleurs de mon point de vue aux
confins de la schizophrénie c'est que
quand on soutient eric zemmour et qu'on
prétend est toujours haut et l'air c'est
quand même particulièrement bizarre
particulièrement bizarre un moment dans
la vie il faut savoir trancher peut-être
est-ce votre problème donc où vous êtes
chez monsieur zemmour ou vous êtes chez
les républicains mais vous n'êtes pas
chez v2 5 ce n'est pas possible voilà
pourquoi je voyage je suis fier des
résultats j'ai encore reçu mon courrier
aujourd'hui non mais on me demande de la
forcerait je vous dis on assure que je
dis là arrivent et reste donc je ressens
c'est une posture qui étaient entravés
coeur joie pour ça veut dire cette
lettre c'est uniquement pour pouvoir
brandir cette laisse c'est uniquement
pour pouvoir vous en targuer et c'est
uniquement pour en faire une publicité
qui est parfaitement
excusez moi mais indigente donc très
sincèrement ce n'est pas très
intéressant tout ça n'est pas très
intéressant ce qui est important
aujourd'hui c'est le projet que porte
valérie pécresse pour les français qui
est un projet pour tous les français
park est un projet qui est sur deux
chances d'accéder moi je me suis régalé
sur les champs elysées raison on va voir
est invité pour un autre débat mais tout
de même sur ce coup de fil logique c'est
reconquête évidemment vous avez beaucoup
un
allègrement plus est pas membre de robic
à tout ce
qui soutient la démo non mais c'est un
rapport c'est vrai
c'est une réussite et je rajoute
quelques battues
quand il ya eu un sondage qui a été
effectué auprès des sympathisants lr on
s'est aperçu que si eric zemmour avait
participé la primaire il aurait gagné à
44% au premier tour alors de la rive de
la première d'eric c'est que ces cas
donnez moi la force exceptionnelle
soutien d'eric zemmour allègrement
communiqué voilà les équipes ont décrit
ce coup de fil on est chaleureux est ce
que vous êtes certain effectivement que
cela cela va servir le candidat que vous
soutenez eric g vous savez moi j'étais
en floride il ya deux semaines et
j'étais avec deux ingénieurs le fils de
donald trump et sa femme king est folle
on a parlé un petit peu oui je pense que
c'est important
fait important pour le pour eric zemmour
qu'il reçoive je dirais le soutien de
deux dirigeantes dirigeants mondiaux qui
ont eu un impact extrêmement positif sur
la politique mondiale contrairement à
d'autres quand on voit ce qu'était ce
qu'est l'état du monde aurait eu avec
joe biden avec la guerre aux portes de
l'europe avec la guerre en afghanistan
avec le bazar absolument par tout le
monde je pense qu'avec donald trump on
avait un monde qui était bien mieux
tenus alors c'est sûr que vous si
vraiment vous allez véritablement du
côté des manuels la con ce qui me semble
être le cas très prochainement c'est sûr
que vous préférez joe biden alors on a
interrogé noté spectateurs coup de pouce
ou ou coup d'épée dans l'eau regarder
ses réponses à l'instant qui vont
s'afficher jeanne avoir le soutien de
tram n'est pas une bonne chose c'est une
erreur monumentale
un autre télégramme peut-être mathieu
zemmour trump ont toujours eu le même
combat les médias s'acharnent contre eux
alors c'est vrai que ça rejoint le
communiqué officiel de d'eric zemmour
sur les points communs notamment c'est
un axe qui va aider votre candidat selon
vous le camp je vais garder une certaine
le candidat anti élites
vous avez la mairie était journaliste
mais vous avez la bien pensante il s'est
hissé il a passé vingt ans même plus 30
ans à se battre contre tout simplement
ce politiquement correct outre ces
mensonges contre toute cette propagande
qu'on a vécu moi je me souviens encore
un je me souviens encore de nicolas
sarkozy à l'époque qui a appelé barack
obama son copain je me souviens encore
de la 2d dlr qui ont passé leur temps à
soutenir à soutenir les démocrates aux
états unis alors que la famille
politique la plus proche des
républicains français de la droite
française du rpr français s'est
naturellement les républicains
américains mettront pas dit je souhaite
que l'amérique reste l'amérique et
zemmour dit je souhaite que la france
reste la france c'est parfait ça me va
parfaitement va l'élite de bord sur
cette taxe un ces points de ressemblance
notamment le candidat anti élites ça
vous fait peur justement ça du côté de
chez valérie pécresse ça lui manque
peut-être un petit peu justement d'être
juste un élément par rapport à monsieur
30 monsieur zemmour se revendique matin
midi et soir gaulliste qui est
parfaitement inexact
mais monsieur tromsoe moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que sa politique qu'elle
n'aurait pas été du tout apprécié par le
général de gaulle un homme qui s'y
replier complètement sur lui même qui a
replié complètement son pays sur
lui-même fermons la parenthèse par
rapport à votre question
non enfin si vous voulez monsieur
zemmour se revendique du soutien de
cette robe est grand bien lui fasse si
vous voulez ça rejoint complètement ce
que je disais précédemment je précise
pardonnez moi de vous couper mais c'est
important selon le parisien donald trump
a refusé d'apporter un soutien trop duel
à eghezée mou maintenant ils analysent
gars y'a t'il at il précisé donc ça
qu'il ya pas de soutien officiel
maintenant on a non mais mais mais si
vous voulez c'est cette mousse vous
l'avez dit d'ailleurs vous même dans un
sourire c'est cette mousse en fait que
que les amis de monsieur zemmour et
notre interlocuteur qui manifestement
rêverait de vivre aux états unis font
autour de ce lac qui prête à sourire ce
qui est important aujourd'hui ce sont
les problèmes des français ce qui est
important aujourd'hui c'est les
solutions qui peuvent être apportées et
l'intérêt en fait de valérie pécresse
sait que c'est quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui
un bilan derrière monsieur zemmour il a
le bilan de 30 ans de chroniques c'est à
dire de personnes qui a parlé voulait
d'avoir parlé aussi voter kevin françois
mitterrand dont quatre sont légales au
sommet entre les deux ya aussi parlé de
françois qui a voté pour françois
mitterrand façon faut quand même un
moment faut assumer ça aussi il a voté
pour françois mitterrand c'est à dire
que tout ce déclin aujourd'hui vous êtes
en train de dénoncer il y à participer
c'est un point qu'il faut quand même
relevé
valérie pécresse qui est quelqu'un qui a
c'est et qui fera alors la fox vous avez
dit vous avez raison à 18 ans il a voté
pour pour françois mitterrand je trouve
ça nul ridicule pas bien du tout voilà
moi je n'ai pas voté pour françois mi
temps je n'ai jamais voté pour un
françois mi-temps je n'ai jamais voté à
gauche il n'y a aucun problème là-dessus
tout simplement je dis quand on regarde
le aujourd'hui les projets que propose
eric zemmour et valérie pécresse si on a
vraiment au fond de soi je dirais à
coeur la france enfin je veux dire on
est obligé de manger de pencher vers
eric zemmour valérie pécresse s'est
vraiment c'est un clown d' emmanuel
macron en moins bien aujourd'hui mais
j'ai encore
vous dites ça
non vous ne comprenez pas d'armes et je
compte non mais je comprends pas ce que
pour vous c'est électoraliste donc bien
évidemment c'est votre robinet bien sûr
que si votre objectif c'est de le faire
croire et et d'ailleurs vous êtes en la
matière le meilleur allié des modèles
macro parce que et le maquereau essaye
d'installer ce duel là alors qu'il sait
très bien qu'elle soit visuelle esi
parce que c'est du contrat un sondage
qui va vous intéresse alors j'ai une
question de gènes qu'est ce que l'homme
ne fait pas le coup de quibou qui vous
voterez au deuxième tour c'est
complètement ridicule et bien moi je
voudrais vous allez aujourd'hui vous
allez aujourd'hui de façon extrêmement
clair être le meilleur allié des macros
or toutes les personnes qui nous
regardent qu'ils veulent qu emmanuel
macron ne soit plus président de la
république tantôt la seule solution
c'est de voter pour valérie qu'à
regarder mois en juin du second tour la
seule qui soit en capacité entre et
qu'elle est incapable de passer le
premier mois mais là je vais vous
montrer tout ce qu'on arrive à la fin
mais je garde surtout qui vous pourrez
alors c'est un sondage qu'on attendait
c'est pour ça que j'insiste pour me
montrer un peu s'il va certainement vous
faire plaisir philippe karsenty sondages
après le zénith un évidement on parlait
de céline qui se croisent bas voilà
aujourd'hui en tout cas selon harris
interactive emmanuel macron caracole
toujours en tête car 25% au premier tour
marine le pen deuxième 17 émis et vient
3e éric zemmour 14 et demi juste devant
valérie pécresse vous venez de bord
c'est cela c'est ce que vous craignez on
voit là ce n'est qu'un sondage et après
tout vous ne l'avez pas vous l'avez dit
avec grant dente madame c'est selon
harris si vous prenez opinionway elle
est assez aisé les devants et c'est elle
qui est au deuxième tour donc on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui les choses ne sont
pas figées pour une raison assez simple
mm macro n'est toujours pas candidat et
tant qu'il n'est pas candidat eh bien
les choses ne sont pas posées et n'en
déplaise
à monsieur nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
une dynamique où valérie pécresse un
programme qui est diamétralement opposé
à celui des mêmes accroc puisque très
clairement elle veut mettre en place la
république des territoires
elle veut valoriser le travail je vais
vous répondre
top départ à dire autre chose la zeebo
de la faim ce qu'ils vont en quatre
grands tours macron pécresse je vote
très clairement pécresse en cas de
second tour macron zemmour qui voter
pour qui voter vous mais moi je peux
très pour valérie pécresse vous voyez
vous voyez la différence la différence
entre les vrais gens de droite et ceux
qui sont prêts à aller à 20h au
robinet tout et vous irez chez joignez
le monde oui vous y retrouver comme dit
que je désirais leurs petits camarades
vous merci
la soul sera bonne merci en tout cas on
vous invitera pour des débats de fond
tout cas sur les deux programmes merci
philippe karsenty d'être venu merci à
valérie d'abord d'avoir été là également
merci à vous deux
et on évoque à présent le sort des
enfants de djihadistes retenu dans le
nord-est de la syrie qui inquiète
plusieurs ong ont lancé aujourd'hui à
paris un nouveau cri d'alarmé des
humanitaires qui parle de danger de mort
pour ses enfants le gouvernement
français a soutenu le rapatriement des
mineurs mais dans les faits elle la
réalité est tout autre katia technique
le 15 février plusieurs ong dont la
ligue des droits de l'homme amnesty
international ou l'unicef ont organisé
une conférence de presse pour évoquer le
destin des deux cents enfants français
détenus dans des camps en syrie il
plaide pour le rapatriement rapide de
ces petits en souffrance parfois
orphelins dans le nord-est de la syrie
près des frontières turquie irakienne
ils croupissent dans les camps de
rangées de à lol depuis des années ils
vivent dans des tentes soumis à des
températures extrêmes -10 l'hiver plus
de 40 en été ils n'ont en outre ni accès
à la santé nih à l'école et les français
ignorent pour la plupart leur triste
sort qualifié d'infamie par les ong
présentes leur mère ont fait le choix de
rallier l'état islamique ils font pour
cela l'objet de mandats d'arrêt
internationaux qui ne sont donc pas
exécutée or ni l'irak ni la syrie ne
sont aptes à les juger selon le droit
français parce que d'une part la région
syrienne dur ou java n'est pas reconnu
par la france et de l'autre le fait que
l'irak apic la peine de mort en tout
transfert pour poursuite illégale selon
un traité international
mais la france elle pourrait traduire
ces femmes en justice quoi qu'il en soit
ses enfants dont certains sont nés dans
les camps ne peuvent être tenus
responsables des crimes commis par leurs
parents en refusant leur retour la
france entre en violation des
conventions internationales qu'il a
signées qui impose de respecter
l'intérêt souverain de l'enfant et
d'autres pays on te fait le choix du
rapatriement ainsi en 2021 plus de 330
femmes et enfants étrangers ont été
reconduits dans leurs pays respectifs
mais parmi eux il n'y a eu que 7
français interrogés le ministre des
affaires étrangères jean yves le drian
se dit toujours ouvert à des
rapatriements au cas par cas mais
lesquels pour les enfants nous
continuerons pour les mineurs isolés les
orphelins pour ceux dont la mère accepte
le départ et en menant à chaque fois des
opérations extrêmement dangereuse dans
une zone toujours en guerre des propos
étonnants alors que le dernier
rapatriement a eu lieu en janvier 2021
et qu'il reste deux cents enfants a
ramené parce qu'on nous assène que ce
soit la télévision devant la cour
européenne que ces opérations sont
extrêmement dangereux sanitaire français
ce qu'on y voit là pour risquer leur
ville se défend évidemment que dans
s'agit de sané n'en voit que pour les
français c'est qu'on exécute
exceptionnel parce que de plus en plus
la france s'isole elle s'isole et sinon
parce qu'elle ne supporte pas l'idée de
rapatrier des enfants et leur mère donc
on ne supporte pas l'idée de respecter
les conventions internationales
conséquence de cette inaction une
française de 28 ans est morte faute de
soins dans le camp de rage le 14
décembre dernier elle a derrière elle
une petite orpheline de six ans que la
france à ce jour semblent avoir oublié
le président français est il était
influencée par un sondage aux hawks a
paru en février 2019 qui statuait que 67
% des français interrogés étaient
opposés au retour en france des enfants
de djihadistes depuis deux tribunes de
personnalités de parlementaires ont
tenté de sensibiliser à la cause de ses
enfants selon l'avocat patrick baudouin
président d'honneur de la fidh et h
aucun argument humains ou sécuritaire
nous syfy le refus de rapatriement je
pense que la prise de position le
blocage absolu vient de l'église quand
on aborde les ministères certes de jean
yves le drian suit la ligne et d'une
façon d'ailleurs assez scandaleux
quand ils minimisent complètement la
dureté des conditions de détention de
ces enfants mais quand on interroge en
revanche les entourages les directeurs
de cabinet les conseillers de divers
ministères parier du quai d'orsay et du
ministère de la justice il est certain
qu'il y a au fond de ces personnes une
évolution très notable est le sentiment
qu'un bruit il faut les rapatrier où il
faudra les rapatrier et mieux vaudrait
sans doute maintenant que plus tard
plusieurs instances ont été saisis dont
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
et les ong associations espèrent que ce
sujet sera mis en lumière durant la
campagne présidentielle
et pour en parler nous sommes avec eric
revel pour aller plus loin pardon
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous on
voit que cette question est une question
compliquée et en particulier pour le
gouvernement oui c'est une question à la
fois politique mais c'est aussi quand
même une question d'humanité pardon
alors on a entendu dans ce reportage la
position du miz affaires étrangères on
comprend bien l'embarras des uns et des
autres mais moi je vais vous donner mon
point de vue il vaut ce qu'il vaut
autant je pense qu'on doit se poser la
question pour les adultes de les
rapatrier ou pas parce que quelqu'un qui
est parti faire le djihad de son plein
gré dans un pays qui est un adulte
pardonnez moi mais on peut se poser la
question savoir si des toujours
radicaliser et je vais même plus loin
celui qui a commis des attentats dans un
pays précis que ce soit en syrie en irak
ou ailleurs pour moi s'il est adulte il
doit être jugé dans ce pays maintenant
la question des enfants la question des
enfants qui sont issus de couples de
djihadistes parce que vous avez aussi
des femmes qui sont partis faire le
djihad parfois d'ailleurs contrainte
parfois elles ont choisi cette voie ces
enfants n'ont pas demandé à naître ces
enfants ils ont la plupart du temps
puisqu'ils sont issus d'un couple de
djihadiste français entre guillemets ils
ont la nationalité française alors moi
je pense qu'il est il serait plus
raisonnable d'essayer de les rapatrier
tous pour une raison très simple
d'avoriaz la question d'humanité mais
aussi une question qu'on doit se poser
si on laisse ces jeunes enfants il deux
couples jihadistes dans un pays où le
djihad continue de faire des ravages il
ne faudra pas s'étonner que lorsqu'ils
atteindront 15 saisons ou même avant il
porte à nouveau la flamme du djihad
contre des pays occidentaux comme comme
comme le nôtre donc cette question du
rapatriement des enfants au delà la
question d'humanité c'est aussi une
question de stratégie j'allais dire est
ce qu'on veut les laisser là bas pour en
faire des individus qui se radicalisent
rond ou est-ce qu'on veut essayer après
tout on est la patrie des droits de
l'homme de l'est de l'est de les
rapatrier en france dans les meilleures
conditions alors le thème ou avait dit
oui en tout cas jean yves raude le drian
a réaffirmé que paris continuera bien
sûr de rapatrier ses ressortissants
mineurs depuis la série sauf que c'est
vrai qu'il ya souvent deux à vis
notamment l'opinion publique est
relativement contre en majorité un
compte ce rapatriement
craignant peut-être parfois je cite des
bombes à retardement
tout cela pour dire que c'est une
question qui peut s'avérer compliqué
politiquement notamment en période
électorale
oui et puis d'ailleurs certains
candidats aux proches de candidats
parfois on dit n'importe quoi par
exemple sandrine rousseau qui hélas
proche de yannick jadot écologie europe
les verts avaient dit il faut rapatrier
tous les adultes ont radicalisé qui sont
à l'extérieur on les surveille ira mieux
en france soyez bon
c'est pas une caricature puisqu'elle en
revanche c'est vrai que cette question
je commençais par là devient politique
on est dans un contexte élection
présidentielle évidemment abordé la
question du rapatriement des enfants ou
des djihadistes et aborder la question
du terrorisme est immédiatement
évidemment on poserait où on posera des
questions sur le bilan
comment le gouvernement actuel a fait
face bien ou pas bien au terrorisme et
je pense que ce sujet là me semble utile
personne n'a intérêt ce qu'il soit mis
même s'il est majeur dans la corbeille
de départ de cette élection ça sera
selon vous malgré tout un enjeu réel de
de campagne le terrorisme parce qu'on
parle beaucoup de pouvoir d'achat en
parle aussi de sécurité d'immigration
peut-être moins parfois de terrorisme ça
reste important
moi je n'ai pas le sentiment que c'est
un thème qui sera mis sur la table sauf
évidemment c'est absolument pas souhaité
et sauf si un nouvel acte de terrorisme
évidemment avait lieu en métropole ou
dans un territoire d'outre-mer mais je
ne pense pas que ce soit un thème qui va
jaillir naturellement sur la table même
si la france a beaucoup souffert de tous
ces attentats j'ai pas l'impression pour
l'instant les candidats s'en empare on
rappelle le pouvoir d'achat la santé la
sécurité l'immigration ça ce sont les
quatre thèmes qui dans tous les sondages
intéresse les français merci beaucoup et
eric revel de nous avoir apporté votre
décryptage et c'est la fin de cette
émission rendez vous demain dès 20
heures pour un nouveau numéro excellent
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient de grignan aujourd'hui on a une
gauche extrêmement user de
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
sur quarante cinq pays d'afrique
subsaharienne 28 interdisent on réprime
l'homosexualité est globalement vous
observez une violence d'état bien
orchestrée à l'encontre de la communauté
lgbt sur le continent oui bien sûr sur
le plan politique ce n'est demande si
pendant la campagne anges et dans
l'opinion ne veulent que si vous voulez
voter pour tel ou tel candidat
eh bien il va légaliser l'homosexualité
là on sait qu'on peut lui faire perdre
des voix comment progresse les droits
pour les homosexuels sur le continent il
faudrait que les pays africains sachent
que ce n'est pas une bonne heure de
l'acculer à pratiquer la discrimination
match toutes ses enfants ou alors qu'on
nous dise plus que l'afrique est la mère
de nous limiter
[Musique]
salut à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur rt france pour la grande interview
place à une série d'entretiens pour
analyser l'expulsion de novak djokovic
d'australie en janvier dernier le serbe
joueur de tennis numéro un mondial
sanctionnée pour ne pas avoir fourni de
preuves de vaccination anti qu'ovide
dans un pays pourtant très à cheval sur
les règles sanitaires plusieurs semaines
après le joko gaye donc on accueille sur
ce plateau alexis trou de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes géopolitologue
spécialiste des balkans et auteur
notamment de l' ouvrage
géopolitique de la serbie aux éditions
ellipses plusieurs jours plusieurs
semaines même après l'open d'australie
finalement remporté par rafael nadal
dans quel état d'esprit sont les serbes
les serbes sont très sereins et
notamment noah djokovic pourquoi parce
que pour lui c'est une bataille qui va
au delà de
du problème de vaccination il se place
il faut savoir que c'est quelqu'un qui
vient du kosovo qui se souvient très
bien des bombardements de l'otan sur la
serbie et le kosovo en 99 et donc pour
lui c'est la bataille du canda liberté
contre le camp de pression vous avez dit
qu'il était bon qu'il a été expulsé
l'australie mais il faut